hey everyone welcome to games spots day
three stage show from San Diego
Comic-Con I'm your host Chris Waters
joined by my man Eric Tay what up Eric
give it to me
here a we got a lot of stuff to give
away today we got a lot of demos to show
you we've got a lot of floor reports
like checking out cosplay checking out
booths all the cool stuff from San Diego
ComicCon that like really that like
brings hundreds of thousands of people
to San Diego uh at this time of year
every year uh Eric how's your day been
man have you been out and about uh I
went in a little bit uh with Justin we
saw the smog that you were talking about
on preview night that I had not seen so
oh man that thing is dope we'll see that
later a little bit later um and other
than that it's you know it's Saturday
it's day three it's pretty crazy day
everyone's out and about cuz you know
all the kids can go to Comic-Con now and
it's just absolutely crazy inside
absolutely crazy and as a sort of wrap
up bonus for day three you're going to
see a little bit more of this uh in the
upcoming Sideshow collectibl segment but
if you were watching Gamespot on Twitter
you know that we are going to be giving
away a Nathan Drake statue it's in this
box right here and uh it's fraking
massive and really cool the way to to
win this guy just go ahead and find the
tweet on gamespot's uh tweet line this
one that's the one retweet that and uh
you'll be entered to win we're going
going to give it away on Monday and I
won't be doing that uh scatting thing
during that giveaway unfortunately
unless you ask for it hash Chris scat
nope that's a wrong thing don't say
that all right we're also giving away
all this stuff which get in the gam spot
chat and comment and we will uh put you
down on the list we've already given
away a bunch we're going to go through
this stuff uh and give away more but
we're going to go to game demo now
because uh games but first we got Lords
of the Fallen coming up we had them in
here talked about that game which is
like souls in but also very action heavy
looks pretty cool but first it's off to
check out Sonic Boom out on the show
floor and see what the Sonic and All His
crazy pals are up to besides wearing
scarves and looking real
jacked hi there I'm Anna pra Robinson
for Gamespot here on the front line at
San Diego Comic-Con 2014 I'm with my new
friend marchella from Sega marchella
what are you here showing off at
Comic-Con we're here showing off Sonic
Boom which is a brand brand new uh video
game that we are demoing here for all
the fans um Sonic Boom is a new branch
of the Sonic Universe that we've
introduced this year and not only do we
have video games but we also have a TV
show being aired on Cartoon Network in
the fall and we also have a huge new
line of merchandise toys apparel that
kind of thing so many people come up to
us and they tell us all about all their
little history with Sonic and they've
been playing I I met a gentleman today
who's played every single Sonic game and
he's really looking forward to Sonic
Boom because it's a new kind of
refreshing take on Sonic uh what it
means is what we've done is we've taking
the characters for instance and we sort
of age them up and we're bringing back
some of the irreverence that used to be
in the '90s with Sonic um and so that's
part of it and we're giving more
personality to each of the characters so
Sonic now is going to be playing a lot
with his friends Knuckles Tails Amy
they're all going to have more prominent
roles and their personalities are really
coming out and they're going to go on a
lot of different adventures with a mix
of comedy and action so it'll be really
fun um there's still the core
characteristics that made them each of
those characters those characters are
still there so we believe that it's it's
it's great for not only new fans but
classic fans Sonic as well I mean
they'll all recognize these characters
and what's new in terms of the gameplay
what are we going to see that's fresh
for our Wii U version of the game what's
nice is that we've uh developed this
game with a with a us-based developer um
big red button in Los Angeles is doing
the Wii U and San Francisco based szaro
games is doing our 3DS and so they're
bringing a kind of a new take to video
games and they're looking at what kids
like to play and how they like to play
it so our Wii U version has got more
open world exploration combat um and
that kind of thing and then our 3DS has
got some of the classic platforming but
we've got some puzzling we've got also
some more open world exploration so it's
really nice we're kind of enhan the gaml
to sort of what kids like to play today
well I've seen so many people here in
your Booth it seems like you're right it
has been appealing to a lot of people at
ComiCon how's the Comic-Con experience
been oh it's been great I I love seeing
all the fans coming up I love the
enthusiasm so for us it's been awesome
we've had zullian people come for our
Sonic Boom bags and they're wearing it
proudly so it's really exciting that's
great thank you so much for your time I
really appreciate it I am also a Sonic
fan and really identify with him as a
part of my childhood if you do as well
let me know tweet at Anna procer and uh
let's reminisce about some good old
video game gays and be sure to check out
Sonic
Boom it was announced earlier this year
made a big splash at E3 and now at
Comic-Con folks are getting their hands
on it Lords of the Fallen we're going to
take a look at and Steven Skelton is
joining me on set producer on the game
Stephen thanks for coming man thanks for
having me uh you guys have we took a
look at your booth on the show floor a
little earlier on our show a couple days
ago and uh you guys have got like a
challenge there for people playing the
game you've got a giveaway you got the
whole ComiCon production yeah yeah we
have yeah we have a whole set of PS4s
running the game that you can come and
check out and put your hands on play the
game and if you can beat the level all
the way through the boss you can get a
t-shirt uh and we also have Harkin's
Hammer our character main character is
gigantic Hammer replica I feel like your
hands are really not far enough apart to
indicate I can't it's it's really
normous and uh if you go to our Facebook
page um there's a link there where you
can enter a contest to win uh the H win
the hammer and then figure out figure
out where to put it to do with it that's
your problem uh but Lords of the Fallen
uh it's you're giving away t-shirts to
people who beat that section did you
bring a lot of t-shirts or is it pretty
tough it's pretty tough and we got
plenty of t-shirts but it's a it's a
pretty big challenge I because we we've
actually had a lot of people coming and
checking out the game which is awesome
but you know only I mean I don't know
can't say what the exact statistics are
but only once in a while does somebody
actually get through without dying at
least once that's that's the trick you
got you can't die to get you can't die
you could get through it you know just
die a few times have a good time you're
not getting the T-shirt no shirt uh so
the game Lords of the Fallen is a
challenging game yeah yeah it's an
action RPG um it's a it's a challenging
game but we want to make it uh
challenging but not frustrating mhm and
so that's uh that seems like a tough
line to walk yeah no it's it's a very
tough line but um one of the things that
I think works really well in Lords is
the animation system and you can really
see the behavior of the enemies and you
can spend some time observing them and
make tactical decisions based on what
You observe and how they behave and how
they indicate how they're going to come
at you well we're going to get a look at
it right now in action and uh first off
we see our well I hesitate to call him a
hero but protagonist Harkin yeah that's
your that that's your character hen and
uh yeah engaged in a uh combat here and
yeah and you can see like the animation
system is like really nice and smooth
and and the the characters give a nice
uh uh indication about maybe what
direction they're going to swing how
what direction they're going to stab so
you have a chance to actually react uh
to it without getting immediately
clobbered and then swack them with your
glowing yeah staff which is yeah looks
like a a a cleric class weapon um okay
so there's a couple different it's one
character but you can play him in a
couple different classes yeah
essentially there's there's three base
classes of warrior cleric and Rogue and
those determine uh your magical set of
magical abilities and that's what you
get locked into for the for the game but
any equipment you come across any any
weapons or armor or anything like that
you can use you can mix and match so you
can no cleric only roge the cler if
you're a cleric class you can put on
Warrior armor and use Rogue weapons so
you can mix and match to your heart's
Delight you know however you want to
however you want to play very cool uh so
we it looks like have we jum to another
area cuz we're seeing the sword now is
in action and uh the shield which I was
going to comment on earlier did that
just it just looked like a gaping toothy
ma yeah that's is kind of what the
shoulder pads now look like yeah and
that so that they're probably part of
the same set so um but yeah you're not
you're not restricted to using the same
set there there we go you can kind of
see you know you can uh switch out all
your different all the equipment that
you found you know whether it's you know
weapons or armor or anything like that
and uh choose what you want and your
character will change and your
character's appear
and of you know um you know the heavier
the weapon or arm the more uncovered you
are you know the you move a little bit
slower um but you got more protection so
there's there's the tradeoff some sort
of familiar balances and and uh
trade-offs as you said in terms of the
armor that you guys are bringing in uh
what is you know this is a kind of game
that people are familiar with and and
have a lot of passion for uh what's sort
of what are you guys sort of targeting
in Lords of the Fallen to help it sort
of carve out its own niche well I with
or of the Fall what what we're doing is
you know first uh going for a
challenging but not frustrating combat
experience and second uh we have uh a
bit more of a focus on a strong
narrative in the character story okay um
so uh it's uh you know harken your
character is brought into this conflict
because thousands of years ago Humanity
had this huge fight with his evil God
and defeated the God and everybody
thought great we eliminated evil from
the world so now anytime somebody
commits a sin we're just going to Brand
them an outcast and put a tattoo on
their face and you know kick them out
send them out yeah and but the evil
God's forces have been returning to
Earth and nobody knows why and they
figure let's fight evil with evil let's
find the worst of the worst the baddest
dude we can find that's committed the
most sins and set him on this quest to
figure out what's going on and to stop
it and that's you so you are a real
salty dude and uh you are fighting
lot of overdue library books lot of
parking tickets just oh my goodness so
you're a real yeah you're a real uh uh
uh bad dude real tough and uh it's it's
your job to a stop these forces and then
be figure out why they're coming back
and ultimately try and stop if you're
such a bad dude why do you care though
man like you're just like look you guys
branded me a c tattooed my face forget
you what the hell yeah well I mean the
trade-off is like hey you know you do
this then you can rejoin Society you're
but it's also you'll find out this the
story is a has a a little bit of a turn
too where as you progress through the
game you'll start to find clues that
like well maybe this evil God wasn't so
evil maybe he shouldn't have been
banished and maybe I will or will not
try and Reb banish this guy oh all right
maybe this infiltrator who's like
pooping out horrible blade puddles isn't
such a bad guy after all
I got to say this thing is grossing me
out and I I kind of like it is that
weird yeah no I mean there's a there's a
lot of the the different creatures are
really kind of awesome and unique and
yeah this guy the think I realized he
had a giant toothy mouth and torso also
fantastic it just keeps getting better
uh are you guys is that sort of
grotesquery like part of the one of the
design things you're sort of focusing on
in terms of creating that world well
it's it's you know it's it's creating
like a unique creature um that stands
alone by itself that's also distinct
from a lot of the other like major
bosses which are the Lords of this
Fallen God like the generals of his
armies is what the who the Lords are
you're not the Lord you're figh you're
fighting so um and so to make each one
of these guys as unique as and
interesting as possible so you know
there's you know there's that guy uh you
know who's you know the tripty spider
crazy thing and um there's a guy that's
earlier who's more of kind of of like a
traditional giant armored guy who's
who's really menacing so got a lot of
different variety he doesn't necessarily
squirt things out that then grow on the
floor no but he's got some really cool
attacks when you uh uh get him hurt
pretty bad he gets really angry and
tears off all his armor and then just
starts going crazy doesn't seem prudent
but I guess get be a lord of the Fallen
without knowing a thing or two about
killing things uh speaking of there was
a few uh moments we saw there that were
sort of like uh execution moments or
something a little earlier on uh so the
the enemy Behavior changes over the the
course of the battle Yeah in some ways
yeah and it's also and it's and as
you're fighting depending I mean you can
you can execute uh timed combos um that
will you know that will you chain into
some of those kind of specific attacks
okay uh so you yourself does now do
those combos are those things you kind
of learn are they weapon dependent are
they just kind of a general attack
pattern it's it's an attack pattern of
and and based on you know position and
timing where you are in relation to the
enemy and then it'll kick in Okay cool
so it seems like you know you guys have
you have sort of the the evil versus
maybe good story stuff going on you've
got a couple inflection points in this
story but seems like a lot of your
focuses on that combat well yeah I mean
that's that's the core of the game I
mean that's the heart of the game is the
you know is the is the intense uh
tactical combat uh oneon-one or a couple
on a couple on one so it's never going
to be like you know aund guys coming at
quack quack quack quack it's very
tactically you need to be engaged with
that enemy and you know sort of reading
them and reacting to them as opposed to
just threshing your way through yeah you
don't get too far just running in and
just starting to hack away very cool uh
are there any other sort of modes you
guys are putting in here in addition to
sort of the main thrust of the the
campaign um no well I mean that's that's
that that's the main uh game itself
there are like side quests and stuff
that you'll find so in how the in how
the game is structured so it's kind of a
a network hub so there's a there's a
central Monastery that you keep
returning to and finding new uh bits and
pieces of the story and equipment and
areas and then as you go out to
different areas oh so you can kind of
choose which areas you a little bit a
little bit of that so and there's also
with um the uh the limited edition uh
which if you uh pre-order that you
automatically get bumped up North
America South America you get bumped up
to the the limited edition and that
includes a DLC package which has uh an
additional Quest and a demonic weapon
set which gives you a a set of daggers
and a sword and a hammer in the
soundtrack just some normal looking
daggers though I mean no they're Dem
okay they're demonic and as we saw maybe
normal looking demonic daggers certainly
have a flare for the the Demonic I guess
uh so folks who are interested in the
game um what platform is it coming out
on uh it's coming out uh for nextg
systems so Xbox One PlayStation 4 and PC
next all right very cool uh is that and
you guys are targeting a release this
year or like early next what you 28
October 28th not even a Target you guys
are our releas dat very cool I think
I've got a question or two coming in
here uh let me just check on that real
quick uh while we're doing that tell me
a little bit more about uh Harkin and
this sort of I mean does he do you get
to know him as a character or is he sort
of you the player as a character have
voice acting no he's got voice acting
there's a character and there there are
story element and cut scenes that you'll
find throughout the game that'll kind of
ill illustrate in his backstory and what
is currently happening to him so yeah
you're you're driving him um but you
also you know get his character all
right and we've got a question coming in
over Twitter wondering about actually
the character choices because that's I
feel like that's that's something that
people like really sort of perk up at is
oh I can I can choose I can make the
game different for myself you know I
might want to replay it like are there
many of those sort of sort of moments or
is it just kind of at the end you decide
the fate of the whole world well no I
mean the the the the you know at the end
there's there's a couple of uh ways the
story can end so you can go back and you
can you can play it uh a little bit
differently okay or you can go back if
you want to like hey I want to redo it
as uh as the warrior class you know
there's at least three different classes
so you can you know you can play through
it with the three different classes and
the three different sets of magical
abilities by itself and the Magical
abilities we saw I think it felt like
most of the attacks we were seeing were
melee based were how much how much sort
of is a balance between melee and magic
in your attack patterns um well the
magic is really meant as kind of like
your big gun okay so you're it's meant
to be used once in a while as opposed to
the the weapons which are your primaries
so they're basically you know the magic
is used as like okay I need I need help
to get out of a bad situation or I you
know I want to use it very tactically U
to whittle down a bad guy and there's
actually another question coming in
about the magic for each class that's
the that's the distinguishing Point
really so can you give us example of how
those are delineated well it's it's
basically you know you can you can
probably uh uh imagine from the
different classes you know uh you know
Warriors more offensive uh types of
magic uh the cleric is more defensive
and kind of like one of his things is
you know he can create duplicates of
himself that will fool enemies so it's
really good to use some some of the guys
you can get behind a guy and uh uh get
him and the the thief is a little more
stealthy so it's kind of it's kind of
kind of going along those lines all
right Stephen well Lords of the Fallen
coming out say that date again October
28th October 28th for Xbox One PS4 and
PC thank you so much for coming by
thanks a lot showing the game off and
talking about it that's Lords of the
Fallen folks if you want to know more
check out gamespot.com we've got a bunch
of videos and articles up on it you can
get a bigger meteor taste and it might
taste weird because of all the demonic
stuff but I think you'll like it
yeah hey guys Justin here and I'm
talking with Francis the senior director
of marketing over here at Capcom and
Capcom as always at San Diego ComicCon
has some awesome merchandise if you
could tell me walk me through maybe some
of the cooler things you guys are
selling this year Well Justin this year
actually Capcom always known for having
a really vibrant store with a lot of
selections of exclusives and things for
our fans this year is our biggest store
ever with over 95 products first and
foremost uh our hottest item right now
is the Mega Man replica helmet as you
see here if it's first time ever this
has ever been done which is hard to
imagine you think it would all these
years right and what's cool about it is
it made out of chrome resin the helmet
comes off the base and it's lit up so
it's powered by a USB cord so it could
go connect to your computer or to an AC
adapter you can take the helmet off on
um it comes in the standard Mega Man
blue as well as a variant when he's um
in in the red so right now though the
red one we have a more limited number so
we're limiting to one per person the
other cool items we have is for Monster
fans we have this monster hunter plush
for Theon and the Ute Yan cot cot uh
creatures um comes in a nice little
eggshell packaging plus you can you know
display it in half of the eggshell it's
balanced by itself fans are loving that
too other things we have to move on is
for Street Fighter fans we have oh we
only have one well we had Chun Le here
and we had Ryu here they're sold out
that's how it goes with ComicCon right
things sell it really fast I feel kind
of sad for Ken though he's all sad and
lonely by himself really sad but you
know what's cool about is the first
appearance ever of Ken is by a company
called IP Factory and what's cool about
this plush is there's a wire
infrastructure in the body so you can
actually pose his arm and legs into
Street Fighter type moves so N is a cute
it's kind of like an action figure too
um another Capcom store exclusive is the
street fighter watch now this is a true
high-end collectible last year we made
one a Resident Evil Umbrella Corporation
watch all black with the umbrella logo
this year we're following up with the
street fighter watch with the shadow
symbol right there at the 12:00 point
it's made by a company called Meister
it's high-end Japanese watch technology
stainless steel 10 meters water
resistant leather band individually
numbered only 250 units uh comes in this
nice uh display case with the shadow
logo retail $250 and we've already moved
by 50 of them it's only been halfway
through day one so those were the true
fans uh some other things I like to show
is Street Fighter assassin's Fist is our
liveaction web series that's uh debuted
on machinima.com uh a couple months ago
and this is this is the first time we
have T-shirts and gears iPhone cases
belts all that related to that and Ultra
Street Fighter 4 just came out last
month for DLC and it's also going to be
available for 360 and PS3 on August 5th
so to celebrate that we have the
exclusive t-shirts by company called
caned featuring Hugo decapre rolento
poison and of course Elena so those are
just some of the um some of the items we
have uh we do have also a Mega Man denim
jacket which we can go over take a look
at later that is all hand stitched we
only have 80 units of that for the again
to True Mega Man
connoisseur yeah let's go over and check
out that
jacket so here's the jacket you said
there were only 80 of these made no
there was 300 of them made 300 made we
had 200 as a pre-order and then we have
about 80 left it's hand Stitch it it
says Mega Man Without screaming Mega Man
right nice subtle designs shows his
color schemes even the zipper yellow
where the Buster would be um we I would
like to show you though this Mega Man
Buster that's made by Think Geek our
friends a think eek this is only a
prototype it's not for sale everyone's
disappointed but what's cool it's hard
ABS plastic you can stick your hand in
there and lights up it makes the pew pew
pew sound and um we're just letting fans
see it's the first prototype first
working prototype anywhere let the fans
see it now it'll be available this fall
thank you very Coy much some of the I
mean like I said we have like 9095
products but those are the key things
that everyone's kind of going for this
year at San Diego Comic-Con is there
anything that you in specific you know
you set aside for yourself you're like I
I have to keep a have to keep this for
for myself uh I might hang on to that
Mega Man Buster prototype how's that
it's the only one there is awesome well
thanks so much for talking with me
Francis some awesome stuff here at the
San Diego Comic-Con from the capcon
booth and we're going to be checking out
more stuff so stay
tuned one of the coolest spots to visit
at San Diego ComicCon is the sideshow
colle Collectibles Booth you saw us
taking a tour of it earlier and now
we've got Mike Tolentino here from
Sideshow Collectibles with his buddy
Nathan Drake and uh Mike thanks for
coming by and bringing your friend thank
you for having us uh it was it was fun
it was an adventure getting here Nathan
always gets lost um we have our Nathan
Drake premium format figure available at
sideshow.com uh this is a cool figure
because it's got the full the full cloth
costume I mean he's from head to toe
he's got the pants on the the thermal
you can you can half tuck that thing in
the back you can for for swag he's got
the Swagger for that that quintessential
Drake Look yes uh he's got his little
his little scarf for when he's chil mhm
and his banders are all it's all leather
it's all hand stitched you can see the
uh the the the thread lines and
everything it's really cool really well
put together and you can put this on
like you were putting this together
earlier and I hope you don't mind me
calling you out I I totally messed it up
you had the vandelier on the wrong way
we checked the image and it's like whoa
whoa whoa we got to get our Dr he had to
authentici me yeah uh but yeah so we
you can dress it you can customize it if
you don't want his man purse on he can
take his man purse off or statel if you
will um but yeah so stel yeah that's a
good that's a good word man Pur uh but
yeah so it's you can do it in a lot of
different ways he also has a switch out
hand um that comes oh God so you can
pull that off you put his pistol in you
can take his pistol out of his holster
there so it's there's a lot of different
options we try to make it so you can
have fun with your statue and it's not
just it's not just a static thing you
know I mean it goes on your mantel piece
next to your picture of your family and
other cherished items it's like family
grandparents Drake yeah in in that order
you know we got we got to have some
perspective and uh yeah this is cool and
just we're trying to do we don't just
want guys that are standing still we
want to make our statues sort of leap
out and he's literally leaping over this
wall at you and it's again it's just a
really Dynamic piece and we're uh we're
we're giving it away here yes we are
yeah that's the that's the extra
exciting thing is that you can win this
uh all you got to do is go on Twitter
Gamespot just tweeted uh giveaway uh
tweet there it is all I have to do is
retweet that this weekend on Monday
we'll be picking the winner and giving
this away to a a happy and healthy home
fortunately cuz you know Nate has seen a
lot of stuff he needs a good solid home
some love supportive leave some water
out for himh he gets thirsty with all
the mantling and the flinging himself
hither and yawn very cool Mike uh but
you know you guys have a huge booth at
the show floor as well as a bunch of new
stuff you're showing off at San Diego
ComiCon talk us a little bit about that
stuff uh side collectibl Booth 1929 uh
we're showing tons of new stuff right
now our DC uh statues that we're
revealing we have our backgirl which is
brand new power girl and the Lobo which
is cool Lobo is about this big he uh has
a companion piece as dog which is a roed
out Pit Bull or uh Bulldog nice um and
he's got two heads he's got a switch out
smon bisy head to make it more the
classic and then he's got these cool
dreadlock space dreadlocks it's
fantastic space dreadlocks space
dreadlocks you had you had me had space
dreadlocks um switch out hand with the
with a flaming skull he's got a sickle
it's just really cool and leather work
or our cut and SE team really really
puts that Dynamic touch to it because it
just adds a different layer to the you
used that term earlier cut and SE team
so like give me the give me the
structure of like what different teams
so you've got a different team for the
the cloth you te for elements so first
we start off on design and then we'll
break down to a sculpt so uh they'll
digitally do it but with zbrush although
get a big hunk of clay and sculpt it by
hand U and then from there we mold it
out and then it goes to uh our paint
team and our cut and sew team so the
paint teams will paint all the different
parts of it yeah that's how you get the
uh 5:00 I've been lost in the desert for
we Shadow and then our cut and SE team
will put together the costume on a body
and we'll send that out to make sure we
can get the right materials so he has
that dingy dirty look to his clothes
it's not just brand new cotton it's I
mean you can see it's all just detailed
and weathered and he looks gross he he
looks like he smells let's get a nice uh
nice butt shot there there we go looking
good Nate tucked yep get the half tuck
yeah totally so no [__] stamp so you've
got so you get it so you get it together
and then uh do you have to sort of
consult with naughty dog or Sony NAU dog
uh they they work with us almost from
the beginning as far as approving the
concept and then making sure that we
represent what what it is they want us
to to make for them cool uh so you know
obviously Sony and naughty dog you guys
have worked with DC you've done a ton of
work with uh but that's not the limit of
side colle yeah we also have Marvel uh
we just actually revealed some Marvel
six scale figures which we're really
excited about those are the articulated
12-in figures okay six scale what that
means that
they're yeah one six so if you were
you're one scale yep so if we did a
quarter scale of you it'd be this guy
and then if we did a a six scale tall
yeah about a foot tall 30 points of
articulation um and we just revealed at
the show our dead pole and our Wolverine
figure and those both are amazing there
what's cool about these ones is we're
taking a little bit of license artistic
license of how they're designed so these
aren't designs that you've seen before
in Comics The Wolverine actually has
like like a brown leather look to him
and he's got these cool gauntlets on his
forarms so he they're we're doing a
little bit beaten off the beaten path
that's really interesting cuz I mean
within comics of course we've all seen
superheroes have umpty in costumes
depending on what incarnation of the
hero it is uh but for you guys to get to
sort of put your own creative spin on it
that must be pretty cool yeah the
creative team has a blast doing it
because they're I mean we're all fans of
the properties and we all have ideas of
what they should be and how they should
look so it's a culmination of just just
everyone's working together which it's
always a great end product and we were
talking earlier speaking of the sort of
that creativity you guys are really
getting to flex that now with your the
new thing you guys are taking on yes the
uh the court of the Dead Court of theed
dead.com um that is her own IP s our own
independent property and it is
incredible uh the the story is Heaven
and Hell have been Waging War for ever
mhm and Mankind's souls are trapped in
the middle so death is tired of it and
he decides he's almost like the
Professor X of the underworld he starts
taking all these souls and Gathering his
his court of the Dead to rise up and
overthrow Heaven and Hell the the motto
is Rise conquer Rule and there's three
factions so there's flesh bone and
spirit exactly it's kind of gross a
little gross but kind of cool but you
need all three to survive you need your
flesh you need your bone you need your
spirit naturally that's science exactly
science we've all we all learned that
and they all work together and
it's almost a A Game of Thrones in the
Underworld cuz there's a lot of
political Intrigue backstabbing uh not
only do we have these statues that we're
putting out but we have a graphic novel
in the works we have possible video
games in the works we're really
spreading it out to get this property
and everyone's been super excited about
at the show if you're at the show come
to the booth there's a full like circus
tent in the middle of our uh on the
middle of the booth floor and you can
see all the future offerings that we're
going to have of court of the Dead neat
now that's I mean it seems like you guys
a Sideshow Collectibles you have this
creative team that is you know
responsible for taking what a still
image of Nathan Drake or maybe a 3D
model and turning it into this that big
Dynamics you you've got the creative
engine there and you know that
interpretation it must just be pretty
freaking cool for the artist to get to
conjure things out of their own brain
and they can go unchecked too which is
great because we don't have to be bound
by like we said we love working with NY
dog and Star Wars and Marvel and DC yeah
but to be able to play in our own
sandbox it's super fun just cuz it's
everyone's flexing their creative juices
and it's the product speaks for
themselves you can tell it's a labor of
love and so it's not just going to be an
assortment of figures or and statues
it's going to be a graphic novel a
graphic novel in the works we might even
do different formats of the figure so
they're right now they're all quarter
scale but they might if the if the
interest warrants they could go to 12-in
figures they can go to life-size busts
we have some uh so we have a lot of
things planned it's just depends where
the uh momentum takes us sure depends
yeah sort of what catches on and where
you guys sort of feel like you want to
go with it uh do you have a favorite
among the the court of the dead of the
Dead um there's a figure called agale
which is the Executioner mhm and he's
got it's disgusting he's got these
little fingers over his under coming
under his chin and he's got this dog
that we call dog lail and he's got human
hands for Paw the dog has super for
creep super creepy and then there's the
Red Death which it's the guy holding m
and just is what we call it cuz he's
just holding his inner it's this
more I think that was a design more in
there that was the art Direction but you
know they all they all look great and
they look uh like I said everyone's the
feedback on it has been super positive
so we're really excited I take it back
it's horrifying that you guys are taking
your creative license with this stuff
it's a little bit scary that that's what
comes out of us I'm a little frightened
uh but very cool for you guys at
Sideshow Collectibles and if folks are
interested in coure of the Dead they can
check stuff out Court of thead cour ofth
dead.com uh we also have a number of
giveaways this year we're doing uh if
you go to cour ofth dead.com you can win
the the queen of the Dead if you go to
sideshow.com
wins sololo you could win the life-size
one to1 Han Solo life size life size one
to one so about that so if you have
someone living with you you'll have to
have them move to the closet sure yeah
Han Solo requires a bedroom he does a
themed bedroom uh we're giving away Hulk
statue from The Avengers so that's
sideshow.com smash MH that's the mikette
from The
Avengers uh and we're giving away Harley
Quinn so that one I believe is
sideshow.com
Harley and so you guys you actually sell
these things too though we do yeah you
just do a bunch of giveaways we we spend
all this time and we just hand them out
like candy no yeah sideshow.com is our
it's our main website it's um it's our
blog it's our store uh we sell direct to
customers you can also buy them at your
local comic book stores if they carry
them but um yeah the the store the
customer service team at CER is great
they'll help you out we have Flex Pay so
when you can afford it we can just take
your money a little bit at a
time very uh accommodating love you Mike
I'm very generous we're givers it's what
we do we give you opportunities to give
us money in exchange for this cool stuff
of course Nathan Drake here is one of
the giveaways and we're doing it through
Gamespot through the generosity of folks
here at Sideshow all you have to do is
get on Twitter follow Gamespot and find
that tweet about the giveaway retweet it
this weekend and we'll be picking the
winner on Monday Mike Totino thank you
so much for coming on by thanks Chris
thank you guys for the for the Drake
we're going to find him a happy home and
uh sideshow.com cor ofthe dead.com check
it out folks thank
you so if you want Nate Drake to be
gracing the mantle piece next to Graham
Graham and the fam we got this box going
to send it to you do a retweet and you
can win it and you can pop off its arm
and freak everyone out in the chat
that's right chat gamespot.com
twitch.tv/ Gamespot uh join us there
we're there chatting and taking your
questions during the tape segments and
whatnot and also uh getting prepped to
give stuff away because we've been
giving stuff away Tay all the time uh
speaking of which you guys saw in the
Capcom Booth those Mega Man helmets and
you've seen if you've been watching why
don't she gr when don't she gr you go
you get it gent gently I got it Eric
broke a phone before the show no I
didn't it was your own sort of uh check
it out Mega Man helmet we're giving this
away to you to put on your cat or not as
you see fit the way to win this is do a
little Photoshop little image editing
put uh what do we want Peter cat as Mega
Man yeah photoshop your cat as Mega Man
or anyone from the series Photoshop a
cat as Mega Man or anyone from the Mega
Man series and Peter Brown will
adjudicate and uh decide who gets to win
one of these guys you don't have to have
Photoshop skills you there are free
online editing programs there's
literally no barrier here except like
your Twitter account and some of your
time uh we have been giving away schwag
from Comic-Con the whole show every day
and I'm going to read off a list of
winners here because we got some people
confused in the chat whether or not they
won so we gave away carrian POP vinyls
to the black speed and scraggly bear a
Hardline poster to watch dogs rules
stress cubes to saturated butter gooo
Riot girl Draco hiplet saturated butter
is Rich twice so I guess we have an
extra stress Cube to get away you're not
getting two sorry spy
88 Marlo BC got an Assassin's Creed
t-shirt of which there's one more hold
that up for us let's see that let's do
it it's all folded nicely by Chris until
I yeah this is uh based on the
Assassin's Creed experience here that
you maybe may have seen and procer
Robinson running through uh we gave
Danny i89 The Witcher 3 tote bag which
was full of a bunch of Witcher books
which have been won by Lando plumbley
yellow Sanchez j4r 4te and pixels and
nonsense we also have four Witcher
Comics right here yet to give away as
well as this Witcher art which comes
with a code to get beta access to The
Witcher digital Adventure board game as
well as a Witcher Comics so Witcher
Comics Witcher art with the board game
giveaway t-shirt we've got the zerol
figures to give away that's a Starcraft
thing there
invisible I mean you can you can see
them they might glow in the dark it says
some weird alien stuff on it you can win
it uh we also gave away the nether fairy
dragon from the blizzard Booth to rusher
25l and girl Draco and Mr BL big glasses
gets a rise of the incarnates comic
we've still got some plushies to give
away hold up The Whimsy show Goblin will
you
Eric Eric what does that thing sound
like say something in its
voice pretty good not bad
you did a good job thank you we're
giving away two of those and a whole
bunch of Halo Nightfall posters which
you see over next to Eric yeah oh and
you use The Witcher book to prop it up
yeah you can win one of these guys and
also the final bit of Witcher swag a
notebook Witcher 3 wild Hunt so how do
you win all this cool stuff join us in
the Gamespot chat and just sound off
we'll be taking winners from there and
uh giving stuff away pretty fun it's
pretty fun to give stuff away t don't
you think yeah yeah I mean who who
doesn't want to win some sweet swag and
goodies nobody doesn't not want to win
it I think is an okay way to say that I
guess so all right well we've got
another game demo coming up for you
project cars we checked out some racing
in uh that new sort of uh Community
crowdsourced racer it's a little
interesting how they've gone about the
development process so stay tuned for
that but coming up first we're going to
be checking out Ubisoft and what they're
up to here at Comic-Con there some
assassination there probably some Far
Cry in there probably not assassination
not yet we're going to check out some
smog cuz remember that Dragon we talked
about my document is inaccurate well you
know sometimes people like to feed you
Mutiny miss you toss it some bad
information but I believe production
over there said we're going to check out
some smog um so let's uh go check that
out a big dragon head and
stuff hey guys Justin hey wal here from
gamespot.com we're hanging out at San
Diego Comic-Con 2014 and right now I'm
at the weda booth talking with Luke
Hawker who is the mold room team leader
for weda what is it that you do exactly
for for weda here uh well I'm in charge
of uh making sure that the products we
make and the the props that we're making
for films uh get reproduced in the right
ways so whether it be uh for you know
for a for a computer game uh sort of um
publicity or for an actual movie uh I
make sure that what what we make and all
the art that goes into it gets to be the
final product and be made in a in a way
that's appropriate and gets to be
smashed around as much as it can be yeah
so movies and video games you literally
bring this stuff to life and one of the
reasons that we're here is because
nothing stands out here at Comic-Con
more than this massive smow dragon and I
was told that you had a direct hand
making this this huge creation yes well
um uh the team back in uh uh in New
Zealand they they made the model of the
dragon and then it was milled out and us
a group of sculptors you know made it
look as good as it did and then it was
my job to get that sculpture and uh
reproduce it in a in a product called
fiberglass which was going to be able to
be put up at the booth so I had to break
it into a whole bunch of pieces put huge
split lines in it and make sure it could
go up and only weigh about 1,200 lb yeah
what is it that goes behind putting
together something that's that's just
big and lights up and has moving eye
parts and uh it's a lot of um scratching
your head and trying to figure out which
ways you can break uh things and break
molds and make sure that uh it does what
you need to do but it's a lot of reverse
engineering and then Forward Thinking
and a lot of experience comes into it
and you also have some more stuff on
display here at the booth I mean there's
a lot of really awesome weapons and neat
things here you had a direct hand in
putting this book together over here uh
yes um this this book is a 20th
anniversary of wer because uh W's been
around now for 20 years at the company
uh and Richard asked me if uh being with
the company for 14 years if I would
write uh the history of of wther which
was a very daunting task um and I I said
I would and yeah I I decided to to do do
the team the best I could and and give
everyone an insight into the company but
also what it is we do and there's quite
a bit of technical uh stuff in there
which has um been a bit silly because
I'm a bit of a silly person but it uh
hopefully it's a good read and people
can learn about how we make the things
we do and and I think the Lord of the
Rings and The Hobbit have really
elevated what people know about and what
they think about what but you also do a
lot of really cool stuff with video
games and and I think you were saying
that you've done some work with Tera uh
yes uh tra approached us to do some
promotional uh items for their for their
game and so we've made some high-end um
representations of their props uh which
we do as if it was like any other
feature film and we've taken their
models and turn them into a physical
thing and age them and then then
reproduce them as any any movie prop so
yeah that was that was quite a cool
project actually to to to get such very
quite large fantasy designs and in order
to make them work physically was very
very very hard but rewarding is that
something that the team uses for
reference or is that something that
they're going to be selling what what do
they use those life-size props for uh
for promotional uh things and also um
sometimes just to to giveaways and
things like that uh to I think blizzard
use us quite a lot to for um for their
staff to have pres and things and it's
just kind of fun in order to see
something that's a digital thing and see
how it would actually be in physical
it's it's quite cool and Terra Is Not
The Only Game you've worked on there are
some other projects you've been doing as
well uh yes gray goo where to did a
whole bunch of design our design team uh
work work in all different fields and
they did some design work for greay goo
and we just come off a really really big
uh uh franchise that I I can't really
talk about um but that was a a really
awesome project like that that really
pushed us and um and we're all really
got behind it and it very happy and hope
the fans are happy once it comes out
that that we did the the the game
Justice well I know a lot of people will
be really excited to to find out what
that is and you know everything that
what it does is is literally real
looking like you it's something you can
reach out in touch um thanks so much for
talking with me Luke you're welcome
thanks uh thanks for coming along and
for even more San Diego ComicCon news
stay tuned to
gamespot.com hey there folks Chris
Waters here at San Diego ComicCon on the
Gamespot stage and joining me now Brian
Hong director of marketing for project
cars Brian welcome thank you uh excited
to have you here uh Comic-Con treating
you guys well yeah we're having a great
time we got our booth on the floor
showing off all our games including
project cars including project cars
which we've got in action right now and
uh this is you know it it's one of these
uh your guard variety beautiful racing
game that like makes you really glad you
bought an nextg system right absolutely
absolutely yeah we're really excited
about the game uh project cars is the
community assisted racing simulator uh
by the studio slightly mad for racing
game fans they'll remember that those
are the fellas that were responsible for
the Need for Speed Shift Need for Speed
Shift uh we got a lot of fans of that on
Gamespot actually and uh you said
Community assisted right so what what is
that I mean I feel like the challenge
for a racing game is to carve carve out
a niche and it sounds like Community
assisted is your thing what does that
mean yes this is the first AAA racing
game that was actually crowdsourced so
through the world of mass development uh
the studia has been able to get uh
donations and members uh to join this
community and they've been getting
access to play the builds every couple
of weeks and provide tons of their
feedback on what they want in a racing
game do they want that turn to be a
little wider is that us they want to be
unforgiving you know they uh they it's
been great because they've been
providing a lot of uh reference imagery
uh a lot of feedback on the handling oh
cool so yeah the studio has said you
they like to say that this is a racing
game for Racers bu Racers buy Racers
yeah so that's the question I mean you
know you're getting feedback on the
handling of these cars and I feel like
the the kind of people you know not
everyone who's given you feedback on it
has been behind the wheel one of these
onor racetrack but uh so but there are
these Enthusiast communities that you
can tap into and the knowledge base
there is just tremendous it is and and
because they've been able to give that
feedback it it's actually allowed the
community an unprecedented level of uh
involvement you know in the game design
M uh they run polls to see you know what
tracks do you want what cars do you want
so they're really uh it's not just kind
of lifp service like hey thanks for your
money we're going to go make the game
they've been asking hey what tracks do
you guys want to see what cars do you
want in the game how do you want the
game to be you know set up and put
together so and I I imagine that's can
also get a bit challenging for you guys
because you know yeah I want to see uh
every licens track across the planet I
want to see some space tracks I want you
know like I mean you guys got to narrow
it down a little bit there are sort of
developer design decisions you have to
do to sort of pair it down so what's
been the what have been sort of the
boundaries you guys have been sort of
trying to Channel all this feedback into
into well I think the the developer
definitely wants to try and please as
many of the fans as they can but they do
understand at the end of the day uh this
isn't the only bracing game that's come
out up to this point so I think they're
trying to find that good balance between
you know offering out cars that people
want to see uh versus uh having cars in
there that are unique um and you know
maybe not seen before so well which I
got to ask now what what kind of cars
are unique and not seen before I mean
are we talking like concept cars or well
you know they've got a lot of different
cars not just the most modern ones but
they've got a lot of the classics in
there as well um I know that most
recently they've talked about uh their
their partnership with Nissan so the GTR
which is the favorite car of you know
car Fanboys everywhere okay the 2014
Nismo is going to be in the game so that
should be pretty exciting sure that's
probably a car that is can you tell that
I'm not like super car Community well I
no if you get into one of those things
yeah have the acceleration face ripping
it's awesome so yeah well tell tell me
about you know so I am not like a you
know super knowledgeable when it comes
to car racing obviously uh what's what's
in this game for me what do you got well
the the tracks and the cars we've talked
about I think when you think about uh
the level of handling and the game
features one thing that differentiates
uh this uh this game from once before it
is uh when you get started in the game
you're going to have access to race all
the cars and the different disciplines
right out of the gate okay uh that's one
thing that I think the community has
kind of said hey why do I have to race
forever to unlock every single car I
want to grind through this entire class
of cars I don't really care to drive
just to drive the one I really want to
yeah I want to open up the cabinets I
want to see Peanut Butter Jelly I want
to get it all you know you got some rich
cabinets yes delicious yes uh so talk I
guess talk a little bit about the
structure of the game you know is there
sort of do you do you chart a career do
you like sort of work within different
disc car disciplines and car types like
there's the GT RAC there's Open Wheel uh
there's even cart racing um in season
mode you can get right in create your
own race car driver uh and as you go
into the different disciplines and you
uh have success in there uh basically
you'll gain uh the accolades points and
your you know your reputation points and
as you get in when you want to do online
racing with they've tested they St
stress tested up to I think 30 30 plus
at the same time they tested it but
right now uh they are talking about
having about 16 to 20 multiplayer okay
so this is great because if you start
your own Lobby and it's private uh you
can race with your friends if you want
to if you just want to go out and
compete against other Racers of your
same ilk uh the network driver uh Series
in there will actually match you with
people who have about the same level of
driving experience as you as well and is
that so that's tied to that reputation
you were talking about and the in your
your own in-game successes and how much
time you put into it right all right uh
and so in terms of online modes I mean
are we talk talking just kind of like
one-off races like a little racing
series or any kind of grander plans
along like a yearlong Formula 1 racing
competition I I think it's going to
allow you to have the flexibility to do
the one-off races as well as get into
much longer Series in the season so uh I
know that they're still working out a
lot of the details on the setup of the
game as they get in with the community
and keep getting their feedback but
that's and that's and that's that's
leading up to release but if you're I
feel like if you're a Community Driven
game you release the game your community
gets bigger because now people can
actually get the game in their hands you
can let them know through the game like
Hey we're we're a Community Driven game
are are you guys going to be continuing
that kind of support and that kind of uh
you know tweaking and adding new content
based on community desires after release
right yeah because the way that the game
development has gone I mean they've been
constantly getting feedback and running
those tweaks M I think the intent is
fully to continue on getting that
feedback all the way through uh in a lot
of ways this has been uh something of an
experiment in terms of game development
I mean I think fans have never had this
much access and input um and the
developer is I think you know slightly
mad is trying to make sure that uh you
everyone's voices are listen to well
that does sound slightly mad but uh the
game looks like it's shaping up pretty
well and uh I guess is it possible so
folks if they watch this demo and
they're thinking like I'd like to
community I'd like to community
contribute to this this slightly mad
Endeavor is there a way that they can
sort of get involved well they actually
uh on once they started the funding uh I
believe they had over 880,000 uh folks
ultimately sign up to join the community
uh they had six tiers that you could
actually uh buy into you know starting
from Junior all the way to senior member
and that gave you different levels of
access and different levels of uh
interaction with the developer but um I
think right now when you think of just
that alone um that that's kind of unique
but uh another piece that we haven't
talked about yet is virtual reality uh
that's something reality yeah the future
so uh one of the things that they want
uh this game to be compatible with is
the Oculus Rift and the project morphus
headsets so um they'll be giving out
more details on you know how that
actually works but we do know right now
that uh they've been doing a lot of
testing on it they've actually been
posting videos on YouTube sh the you
know the physics with your uh with your
head you know inside the helmet and kind
of seeing the 360 perspective so no kid
uh that is something we're really
excited about uh to show once it you
know kind of gets off the ground that's
neat yeah and it's I mean that's a lot
of developers are sort of telling us
that they're experimenting with it
they're checking it out but like you
know I think that you know in the next
year it's really looming that we're
going to get to see so many of these
games put into the Oculus Rift into the
the Sony Morpheus and uh and see how it
turns out it's very exciting uh but
speaking of peripherals you guys are
also offering uh support for a range of
driving peripherals yes the so wheels
and pedals and ships and stuff like that
yeah I mean there's been a lot of
Licensing Partnerships that the studio
has made uh I know that with
thrustmaster that's kind of a a pretty
pretty uh favored uh you know peripheral
system Absolut very popular uh we got I
got some questions coming in on the
Gamespot comments of uh sort of project
cars stuff we've had up on the site and
uh people are curious about about that
range of cars about you know are they is
it licensed cars and tracks or are you
guys uh have you created any of your own
like original tracks or original cars or
anything like that uh so depending on
the racing discipline most of the tracks
are authentic tracks that you'll see I
think uh some of the tracks are are uh
created by the developer but that might
be more for like cart series type okay
uh but a lot of the the race here that
you see whether it be the mons or the GT
or the tracks that's going to be some
offensive tracks and uh those cart
series racing they've got like Loop to
loops and jumps and items and stuff like
that right
yeah yeah we'll see we'll see all right
so uh project cars it's coming out this
year yes it'll be coming out November of
this year uh the PlayStation 4 the Xbox
one uh the steam platform and then in
2015 uh the first ever Wii U version so
no kidding that's going to be PR crazy
too you going to be like H tap the Wii U
thing to honk the horn cuz honking horns
is like an integral part of car racing
on a professional level as that's been
my feedback I wanted a horn in there so
I could yeah hey we're Community we're
giving you community feedback my voice
count counts my voice counts all right
so uh project cars coming out in
November and uh again for folks who are
interested in sort of keeping an eye on
it and maybe contributing are there
forums or a website they can check out
yeah there's plenty of forums they can
go to the W MD portal uh and find the
cars project cars page in there or they
can go to Project CARS game.com as well
all right Brian thank you very much for
coming by thank you for about project
cars hi there I'm Anna proa Robinson for
Gamespot here on the front line at San
Diego Comic-Con 2014 I have found a very
cool miniature Studio over here I'm
standing with my new friend Dylan Dylan
what do you do uh I'm an animator uh on
Robot Chicken for uh which is produced
at stupid buddy Studios um and uh right
now I'm animating uh some shots just for
uh Comic-Con just doing a little demo of
what it's like to animate on Robot
Chicken and how we do it I noticed right
away that you've got a a very special
power glove here what's going on there I
I modified this Power Glove to be a
Bluetooth controller for uh dragon stop
motion Dragon frame stop motion which we
use to animate the program uh which we
used to animate Robot Chicken and I've
been using this for a couple of years I
I wear a Power Glove to work uh it's
pretty it's pretty awesome I you know I
love the Power Glove it's so bad and all
that not many people can say that they
wear a Power Glove to work or that it
helps them do their daily job yeah I
mean I think uh I've been using it for
about 2 years so I think I probably have
used it more than anyone has ever in the
25 years of the Power Glove I've
probably used it more than anyone very
cool so tell me you know you you told us
on a a large level what it is you're
doing with the glove but can you explain
for someone who might not be too
familiar with animation what exactly are
you controlling with these buttons well
so with the with the number pad here I I
I set it to to switch me back and forth
between uh my my individual frames so
that I can track the motion of the
characters so uh that's how we that's
how we know like when we've moved the
character enough or when we have it
moved it enough you know when we need to
move it more we uh you know
we uh so I I I basically set it up as a
a Bluetooth keyboard so that it I've set
all the hot keys to control the
different components of the program uh
you know that is the coolest Bluetooth
keyboard I have ever seen officially
what kind of films are you making here
what what's going on in this scene right
now uh right now I've got uh old Clint
Eastwood being beat up by young Clint
Eastwood why is that happening well I
figured uh I might as well pit them
against each other and see who comes out
on top I think I think Pro my money is
on Old Clint Eastwood because he's got
some young in Clint Eastwood in him so
he I think he's probably he knows his
moves and all he'll probably he'll
probably win an epic battle indeed well
could you show us a little bit of the
animation process like what each frame
looks like yeah so right now uh so old
Clint Eastwood is coming up and I'm
going to give him a little bit more
right just like this and then I'm going
to check check to see if I did that
right yeah it looks
right
yeah and then this cleint Eastwood's
going to stabilize out and
then yeah and we'll take the frame there
I love he's got the little frowny mouth
on yeah he's it well that's like his
like gritting teeth mouth you know are
those mouth little stickers I see here
yeah they are they're we use uh little
stickers I I also added this little
retractable tweezers so that I could
take sticker mouths off and put them put
them on the characters like I would
probably put it
on and then
he's now he's
got yeah so yeah he now he's got a
little mouth on it s such expression for
sure well thank you so much this has
been very educational and I love the
inspiration of using a game controller
that may not have been so useful in its
day for something that is much more
useful now you know it's important to
improve upon the past you know exactly
exactly well let me know what you think
of that modded Power Glove I'm certainly
impressed are you tweet at me at anaer
and let me
know heyy welcome back we're live here
Chris Waters Eric Tay what up Eric we've
been giving away some stuff got some
goblins claimed got some uh
entries for the Mega Man helmet giveaway
the grand Mega Man helmet giveaway uh
this thing a limited edition Comic-Con
collector's item if I'm not mistaken
Eric don't drop it tell them how heavy
it is Eric how heavy is it I don't know
it's probably like a few pounds maybe
does it fit on The Whimsy Shire or
goblins head without too much squeezing
I don't know here's how you win it
Photoshop a cat as Mega Man or any other
character in the Mega Man series tweet
it to Gamespot and PC Brown cuz Peter
Brown is a generous benefactor
sponsoring this giveaway and he's going
to choose uh do we have we have some
entries already do we have that one
handy to look at maybe we will by the
end of this toss uh We've also got
Witcher Comics that are still unclaimed
as well as a bunch of these Halo
Nightfall posters starring like SP
Spartans would be Spartans they're going
to be Spartans they're not spart this is
the guy who stars in Halo 5 Guardians
before he's an 05 Guardian it's cool uh
Tay what up are you just like cuddling
with that thing I don't know I was doing
like you know little hand gestures while
you're talking to kind of just like pass
the time kind of kind of could you do a
dance number at
least let's see it oh I was talking
about with the cat but that's cool I'll
take no I'll take Tay dance any any
day Turn It Down for What all right so
we're giving the I think the Goblins are
both spoken for at this point yes Lizzy
24 and olac congratulations
congratulations fantastic let's see
what's coming up next shall we Eric yeah
what is coming up next did you refresh
it this time yeah let's see if my
information's accurate why don't you
guys listen up tell me if I'm wrong
about anything all right we've got
another gameplay demo coming up for a
tactics game War Machine tactics so if
you folks are into XCOM or Final Fantasy
Tactics you're going to want to stick
around for that we're also taking a look
at some Batman cape and cowl stuff
that's sff really cool what so what was
that all about um there's like a I think
there was a collection of I want to say
70 hopefully that's somewhat accur a big
number but you know different designs of
capes and cows like together obviously
um and W and Anna went and check that
out so there's going to be a whole
little
Montage uh nice little video with uh a
bunch of cape and cows designs cool very
cool but first a look at project totem a
game showed off at the Microsoft uh game
showcase a cool little indie game oh
there we go and Mega Man
uh that is our first entry in the cat
Photoshop contest for the Mega Man
helmet hopefully we'll see some more uh
before the shows out and over the
weekend you have chance to enter the
Victor will be decided next week just
like the Victor for big NY Drake Over
Here will be decided next week based on
whoever retweets that Gamespot tweet but
for but for now project totem here at
San Diego Comic
Con
maybe hey guys Justin here at San Diego
Comic-Con we're hanging out in the Xbox
gamer lounge and I'm talking with Forest
who's one of The Producers at press play
Studios and she has a really awesome
project that she's working on right now
here in the Xbox gamer Lounge it's
called project totem what what is this
game exactly that you've been working on
so this is a minimalistic puzzle
platformer from press play located in
Copenhagen Denmark and uh yeah we've got
a co-op and a single player and uh we're
just going for a sort of very uh minimal
but playful and and um challenging uh
game I guess the best way to to learn
about the game to describe it is is to
watch it what's going on on the screen
here right now yeah so so the basic
premise is that so we have a single
player right now on screen the basic
premise is that there are two totem
pieces that you control with one input
so he's using the left stick you can use
a d-pad or the left stick and you have
to use the environment to basically
offset or align the totem pieces and get
through your levels what was the
inspiration behind this game like I it's
a very distinctive art style I don't
feel like I've seen something like this
before well this is definitely something
fresh and new for press play but we do
always go for playful so we were in the
completion phase of Max the Curse of
Brotherhood and our composer and audio
engineer was actually needing a creative
outlet and this was a side project for
him he was sort of sitting around his
house one day and thought wouldn't it be
interesting to control two two
characters with one input so we started
working on this uh in his spare time and
there was a party and there was some
drinking and one of our studio directors
Ola had this vague memory the next day
and said hey ASA I remember you telling
me about this super interesting game can
I see it so then what happened was the
studio directors all got really excited
about this project uh we put a team
against it for a month and prototyped it
and uh and then we uh yeah took it to
Greenlight and and this is a project uh
we have a full team of about 14 people
working on it now and we're we're aiming
for end of this year to release on Xbox
one so why totems that's a very
distinctive thing to to pick up on as as
the main character basically why why
totem you know I think that uh I think
that the guys uh ASCO and boat actually
are two brothers who are the really
behind this project and leading the
project I think they just thought it
would be really
fun yeah yeah I I think that they were
like you know Asar as I mentioned as a
composer and I think he was really
interested in this sort of um uh like
music and this Vibe and these beats and
I think uh yeah and it just it made
sense you know to have two pieces and
the other premise is that um you as you
go through the game you're collecting
totem pieces and you're building the
great totem pole so it it makes sense so
as it goes on and on you're actually
adding more pieces that you're going to
be controlling correct correct and as
and as you finish a level you if you do
better you see the points in the corner
the better you do the more awesome your
totem pieces so you might have
sunglasses or a gold pipe or something
like that so and you also have
occasionally have to change the color of
your totem so like you can switch you
have green at the top but that can be
purple when you need to get past these
kind of obstacles right there correct
correct and your collecting it looks
like start buttons on the Xbox
controller it does actually are they
yeah I never thought about that before
it's true but I guess there are also
triangles that that fit up with the
upper left hand corner yes so uh with
each pickup uh basically it's a point
system and you collect them but each
time you die you lose it so we're
playing around with different ideas like
a hardcore mode where uh you can't
die and I don't think it needs a story
because I love puzzle Platformers just
for themselves but but is there a story
behind why they're exploring these crazy
catacombs yeah so okay so the the
background story is that there is a good
Shaman and a bad Shaman and the bad
Shaman basically destroyed the great
totem pole of the world and it's your
job to resurrect it so that's that's the
story behind uh rebuilding the great
totem pole and of course you need
multiple pieces to make a big awesome
totem yes and so you're based out of
Copenhagen I'm sure you're a little bit
jetlagged but is there anything you're
really excited about seeing here at
ComicCon outside of the Xbox Lounge oh
gosh I actually saw um there's some ID
at Xbox games over there that are uh
very very
interesting
um I think lovers is super interesting
and I'm defin lovers in a dangerous
SpaceTime yeah I'm definitely keeping my
eyes out for that cool and a lot of
really awesome Indie stuff here Xbox has
been supporting that in a really cool
way and it's awesome to see these kind
of smaller Indie titles getting so much
love if you want to try it yourself you
can come by the Xbox gamer lounge and
for even more Comic-Con news stay tuned
hi there I'm Anna prer Robinson for
Gamespot here on the front line at San
Diego Comic-Con 2014 and I'm at a very
cool event with Gaz Gaz how are you
doing yeah great thank you this is a
celebration ation Batman 75th
Anniversary it's the cape Cal creates ex
exhibition it's basically an Art Exhibit
we've taken the Batman Arkham Knight bat
suit and we've given it to a load of
artists creatives celebrities and
they've just done their own thing to
create whatever it is they wanted to do
uh their own version of the most iconic
suit in crime fighting so we've seen the
guys from scribbl nut they've created
their own Cape with like loads of
classic DC characters on uh we've got a
a Los Angeles tagging version over here
we've got one that kind of looks like an
ice cream with a waffle cone it's just a
celebration of Batman a celebration of
art uh and uh and what a what better way
to to do the 75th anniversary in style
well I think you know Batman suit is the
most iconic suit in crime fighting right
the bat suit is uh when Bruce Wayne puts
that on he becomes the Batman and so
when the way that we approach our game
design is always to make the player feel
like Batman so I guess you could say in
a sense that that our our game is the
bat suit for uh for for people who pick
up the who pick up the controller great
well in terms of Batman Arkham Knight
when can our viewers look for for that
game and what special things should they
really be be expecting and being excited
for for the game well one of the cool
things about the batsy that we've
designed is that it interfaces really
well with the Batmobile and the
Batmobile is the big thing that we
really wanted we finally wanted to bring
to the Arkham Series so it's totally
drivable it's totally awesome uh and
when Gamers get a chance to play in 2015
they're going to they're going to see
why yeah I did get a chance at E3 to see
that Batmobile and the the cool tactical
movement that you've got going on there
is really exciting so I can't wait to
check that out I'm sure you at home
can't wait to check it out as well let
me know what you're most excited for for
Batman Arkham Night by tweeting at me
anaer out on the show floor at San Diego
Comic Con is a large hulking uh Machine
Battle monstrosity thing and Jay Qatar
pil from white moon dreams is the guy
behind it Jay uh the game is war War
Machine tactics and uh you guys are on
the show floor in a big way yeah
actually so our um so war machine is
actually um an IP that's uh built by
Privateer Press and they they've uh they
wanted to expand it and uh we were we
were really crazy about it so we uh
actually launched a Kickstarter last
year that uh that did really well yeah
yeah and here you are with a game that's
playable yeah it's going to be real
Kickstarter games do happen that's right
that's right uh we uh we actually
decided to kind of Go Big with it so we
uh instead of kind of building like a a
small a small casual game or something
we went for like a full turn-based
tactics game with a 20 Mission uh single
player campaign and 48 you know playable
multiplayer units and like more stuff
coming and all kinds of craziness so
very cool so it's going to be a good
time well we've got a match set up here
uh between you and your buddy Matt and
uh you guys are poised to start doing
some damage to each other uh so right
why don't you get these are these the uh
the aonomus war machines yes these are
uh I'll walk you around it a little bit
here so uh so uh anybody who's a fan of
XCOM like we are we're nuts about XCOM
yeah XCOM and Final Fantasy Tactics a
bunch of us are still playing that too
uh we we took uh we took a lot of cues
from uh from uh XCOM and um and then
there's uh and then War Machine itself
on the tabletop plays you know it's uh
it's a tabletop Miniatures game where
you're building squads and and uh you
know uh growing the uh growing your army
and then taking out taking it out
against the uh other players and stuff
so here we've uh We've we've built a
squad and we have our warcaster who's
uh uh oops she's standing behind the
giant war machines but with this like
really sick looking pick and uh ready to
do some damage got some weird engine
back yeah she's uh she's got a little
Steam Plant on there all all these guys
are steam powered uh and she also wields
a bunch of magic too so uh we'll uh
we'll get a little bit of that going too
cool uh she controls these uh these
warjacks the big guys the big guys yeah
so here we have the Juggernaut mhm and
we got the Destroyer back here and then
we got uh and then we got a bunch of
infantry guys we got the uh Winter Guard
right here oh this guy is the Winter
Guard Rocketeer he he's got a little uh
bazooka type thing with him and then we
got uh we got the manoir here okay I you
know the the Bazooka guy I'm like this
he's got to be crazy to get on the field
next to this giant war machine that has
an axe the size of him and a cannon he's
Fearless man look at look at hang on
hang on hang on let's are we going to
get in there yeah look at that beard on
that Steely determination there he is
that uh that's some we see we have real
beard action there so he he can take on
anybody so uh so our our warcaster here
soraa she uh she controls her warjack so
we're going to she's going to assign
some uh some Focus points to them that
allow them to do special stuff okay um
and uh we'll uh we'll get going so uh
we're we're playing kador that's one
faction we uh we ship with four factions
um and then there's two more coming uh
so this is kador uh against sigar so
here's a here's one of the warjacks from
sigar there's another one here
the uh charger practically tiny compared
to the other ones yeah he's a he's a
light Jack and then uh oh we got we got
another Jack who's uh who's got a big
old buff on him so that's the Lancer and
then here's the war cter for
sigar uh
Striker nice
hair uh so this the buff is I mean is
that a a war cter thing or did the other
sort of so the warter cast uh he's he's
put a buff on this on this unit that uh
gives the unit more defense okay so you
probably want to focus your attack on
the the big guy right front and center
right he's uh yeah he's he's looking
like a he'd like a piece of that but uh
since we're since we're in the middle of
battle here I'm going to go ahead
and take this moment
to uh use my use my Caster's feet which
is a it's a it's an attack that you have
once per game but since uh there's a
couple of his guys round I'm going to
take advantage of the situation and uh
icy gaze icy
gaze and that's just boom ah so that
froze that uh froze whoever was in her
line of sight okay so uh I'm going
to start taking some pot shots yeah oh
actually go go right up next to up to
him and just uh start beating him so I
change my facing facing is important in
the game and uh start beating on him uh
let's boost so much better for you to
attack from the side and to not leave
your side or flank exposed right that's
the whole facing mechanic that's right
that's right you got to you got to watch
you got to watch your back you know and
people can kind of creep around you and
stuff like that you take you take a lot
of advantage of that
so you got like three separate attacks
on that guy and that's the whole power
of like the war cter can assign more
Focus to the to the character uh to the
to the warjack mhm so uh this guy well
this guy's going to take a little pot
shot at him oh actually we'll use the
rocket
launcher and it's giv you yeah oh no
damage didn't do enough damage now did
you like clip your warjack there is
there any Friendly Fire there is
friendly fire so you got to be careful
um if uh the thing has the the rocket
some of the some effects have like area
effects sure you know so you can you can
wipe your own guys out and sometimes you
want to use that like warjacks have the
ability to throw uh to throw um
characters but sometimes you want to
throw your own guys like into the middle
of their fight or into the middle of
their squad and just start you know
beating on them from the center seems
like a bit of a comicazi maneuver I mean
a dude into the fry but hey the uh it's
a tactic that's right it's it's a tactic
and it is a tactics game and uh
privateers uh privateers whole motto for
the game is play like you got a pair all
right a pair a pair of jacks
uh you can call whatever you
want all right so this warjack is like
on the ropes yeah that's what those the
squares is all that is it health he yeah
and since I've frozen him all my all my
attacks for sure are going to hit so uh
let's
uh right because it's on dice rolls
underscore this entire combat system
that's right that's right and actually
we have this whole combat log right here
actually in our UI is All Temporary
right now but you can see our combat log
you can see everything um everything is
recorded so in case anybody wants to get
nerdy about it or something at some
point they uh all the information is
right there I think with a game uh as
tactically in depth as this one the
question is not if someone wants to get
super nerdy about it it's when that's
right that's right so you can actually
scroll back through everything and you
know uh there there won't be any
arguments to have and speaking of when
actually talk to me a little bit about
uh the sort of learning curve here do
you guys have sort of you know tutorials
set up is it I mean certainly there's a
certain amount of tactical awareness
that can carry over from the games you
mentioned earlier like a Final Fantasy
Tactics or XCOM but you have all these
systems that are unique to war machine
right uh so if if someone's not familiar
with the the tabletop game how are you
guys sort of welcoming those players
into the game so we we're doing a lot
actually for that so you know aside from
like a aside from like you know manuals
and stuff that you can get online the uh
the single the 20 player single player
the 20 Mission single player campaign is
uh an extensive walkth through not only
through uh the uh not only through the
game and all the all the little nuances
of it but this amazing lore and the
world that like Privateer have actually
built it's really really cool so
actually the owner of privateer uh and
the guy who came up with all with War
Machine and everything he actually has
written the story and wrote all the
dialogue and everything so oh no kid he
was super Hands-On it's really cool
that's cool for you guys to get to have
that kind of connection to the you know
to the source material yeah it's it's
really nice and the you know the the the
fact that we can work so closely with
them means that that the game is really
authentic to everything that war machine
you know that war machine players the
existing War Machine players are you
know familiar
with so all right so you're you're
putting your guys right in there I I
feel like it behooves you to finish off
the uh I'm going to give it a shot but
uh I I got I got to like you got other
concerns he's going to he's going to
come out he's going to come out strong
here or he's going to come out at least
swinging so we go for going to try and
hit is hit that guy over
there that's a long range shot he was
out of the freeze radius so yeah so he
wasn't Frozen but that was a pretty
strong rooll I mean you almost got him
we expecting to knock him out uh I was
hoping to cuz uh cuz this is I mean look
at the size of that guy right you figure
right you should be able to knock that
dude on his yeah if I did if I uh if I
rolled a little bit better I would have
uh I would have done it uh roll 15 to
hit 10 out of three dice so and you were
telling me this earlier but uh the the
sort of folks are seeing the the blue
outline the red outlines those are
that's sort of a familiar language in
terms of XCOM games that's right uh the
blue you can move and still take a turn
the red is you can get there but you
can't do anything once you're there
right right so we'll uh we'll actually
do that we'll move somebody into into
some trouble there the danger zone right
and then the yellow is the sphere of
influence that the warter has that's
right okay that's right very good I
remembered um and the uh the the game
the the way War Machine itself is played
you know like it's not it's not one of
those games where you kind of you kind
of like run up and shoot and then like
back off uh it's it's all about like
getting into people's faces and fighting
so uh like one of the things that's
that's happened here we have these two
guys who are face to face now and
they're they're actively engaged with
each other if one of them breaks that
engagement they they are prone to get
spaned really hard so this whole there's
a whole concept of free strikes um you
know you it's uh if you get too close to
somebody um and don't engage them you
can you know you can take massive damage
if you try and run away from a fight
that you're engaged in you take massive
damage is that just because running away
will leave your flank exposed for the
next player's turn and just punish you
for that right okay and that's a that's
a you know that's that's one of the
things that's you know one of the big
one of the many things that really
differentiates the uh the gameplay
Styles you know uh between other tactics
games and and uh you're not sort of
doing this stop and pop stuff it seems
like once you're in it you're in it and
it's a very that's sort of a very
aggressive mindset yes yeah it's it's
very much about being aggressive um or
like
sneaky so so what kind when you say
sneaky I mean I'm looking at the
battlefield I don't see a lot of guys
who could do some sneaky Maneuvers uh
there's I mean you're seeing two of the
four factions here mhm
um the uh there's uh there's there's so
there's another faction called CCS which
uh they have you know they they have
strengthen numbers but they also have a
lot of very you know they have a lot of
interesting tactics that you can use uh
units that can pass through other units
and things like that so okay so you'll
uh which might be good for I mean
Battlefield positioning certainly and
also getting taking advantage of the
facing mechanic that's right that's
right all right take this Ironclad out
come on let's see let's see if we can do
it we got a 74 74% chance to hit and the
probable damage is uh is two but if we
crit we can get four to six you just
need one right we just need one just
need one um so let's uh let's hope the
dice gods are with us I believe in you
oh okay oh yeah count crit all right
he's going down he's
down sad time for Ironclad all right
all right now it's Matt's turn to beat
up on you a little bit yes we'll see how
that goes for
you uh so what's his smoke bomb I mean I
feel oh it finished so he's so you're
also seeing on the the combat log uh
sort of the duration of different Buffs
and status effects and stuff like that
that's right yeah you you can see
everything you can see everything that
the that both players are doing and you
know that's having anything that's
having an effect on the game mhm so so
now he's probably uh alloc focus and
then uh figuring out looks like he's got
his uh Lancer selected so he's going to
try and do some damage with the
Lancer now during this phase you you're
just kind of sitting back and watching
and maybe like you're planning
your yeah you're planning your next move
a lot of people uh a lot of people uh
have uh We've noticed a lot of people
like spend a lot of time you know going
over the stats of all the other uh all
the other units and uh we're also
implementing a u Dynamic camera system
very similar to had so uh so you can
anytime anything is going on on the
field like if you want you can have the
camera like zoom into it and take a very
cinematic angle to it and watch this
small soldier just getting stabbed
repeatedly by a spear twice his height
dude his his beard is keeping them
safe power of the beard all things are
possible that's right uh now this is a
one versus one multiplayer match that
we're playing on a land connection uh
you mentioned the campaign that's a
single player Affair against sort of pre
established scenarios you guys have yep
yeah so there's a there's a there's a
single player and then there's also a
single player mode we we have that's uh
just called Onslaught where it's a AI
are just coming at you they just keep
coming at you and it's a survival mode
sure basically so we have that and uh
we're going to expose that to our
dedicated server setup so people can uh
people can a lot of your guys are all of
a sudden lying on the ground yes uh he
he cast ear Quake which just knocked a a
bunch of my guys over so now they're
they're quite sad sorry you were saying
about dedicated servers couldn't
couldn't let the the dudes line down on
the job go without comment you know this
is uh this is one thing we keep uh how
do we make them not look like they're
sleeping or lying down in the job and we
just may have to live with it I don't
know could you put I you can't like put
debris on top of them cuz where did that
come from you know mysterious
debris
uh but in terms of the the online so
online uh so online what we'll what
we'll have is um we already have uh we
already have matchmaking going uh so you
can play with your friends over Steam
and all that sort of thing and uh we
have a um dedicated servers coming up so
people will be will have ranked ranked
servers we'll be doing tournaments and
things like that and we have some we
have some awesome sponsors actually
behind us oh really yeah so uh they're
going to they're going to provide really
really nice prizes I'd like to win some
but I'm sure I won't but no you are not
able to win them when you work for the
company as I well know cuz we give some
cool stuff away here on Gamespot that
Chris doesn't ever get to half I could
touch it but then it yeah I I don't get
to take it home I got that
close uh well I mean so this battle how
long would a battle like this take I
mean you're s we're sort of I feel like
there we've sort of goed you guys to to
get right into it for the sake of the
demo but you know if you were if you
were like really sitting down really
wanted to win this one give me a Range
the battles like when you get when you
get pretty experienced with it it's like
about 25 25 minutes 25 to 35 minutes and
then uh when you're just kind of
figuring things out it's like 45 to 55
minutes uh so uh it's along it's along
the same lines as like uh Dota 2 or
League of Legends you you know you get
in you you spend a you spend a good
amount of time on a match uh and there's
a I mean there's a there's a lot to it
you know just like just like uh just
like uh those games like every every
character is very unique and then the
way that they play with the characters
around them is uh is really unique is
also yeah you got to take you need to
know your characters and the enemy
equally well which is a lot of learning
you guys have like online resources for
this stuff I mean I imagine you're
drawing from established war machine
cannon right so you are you using those
same kind of statistical values as
tabletop game we've uh We've we've taken
the values and we've made them kind of
proportionately fit to uh to what we
have here some in some cases like
they're one for one okay you know um but
uh but we there's a lot of there's a lot
of resources for people like you can you
can select a you can select an enemy
unit and you can see all of their
everything that they can do here and uh
it's not in just yet but uh we have we
have popup text that comes up that
explain each individual thing and then
uh and then there what I need there's uh
there's uh actually our the people that
are already right now uh have been
writing like detailed stuff like this
guy does this stuff and this is how you
should use him and people are starting
to make their own like guid so at some
point I think their information is going
to be better than ours hey that's great
crowdsourcing the information uh that's
a real powerful way to get to create
resources in this day and age it's
pretty awesome uh I mean they do such a
such a great job at it you know well if
people are intrigued by War Machine
tactics uh where can they can they get
it now or do they they have to sort of
wait a little bit for it to yeah so you
can actually hop on uh you can actually
hop on Steam right now it's on Steam
Early Access we're uh we're heavily
soliciting feedback you know all the all
the information that we can get on uh
like what what people think about the
game and balance and what you'd like to
see and all that and uh if you if you
get it now uh we're also we're also
including uh a whole new faction to so
you'll have five factions to play with
and uh another eight extra units so you
get a total of like 20 20 extra units to
play with when you uh when uh when the
full game releases right on uh any idea
when the full game is going to release
uh few months actually no kidding yeah
all right well I wish you the best of
luck in the remaining months Jay thank
you for coming by and showing off War
Machine tactics absolutely that's on
Steam Early Access right now folks you
can check it
out
back
oh
Hello everybody welcome back what did
you see Tay what was your favorite thing
what' you like there's a lot of things I
saw it's it's always good to experience
the ComiCon since I haven't been able to
walk around um you know that that end
shot was pretty great all the
Stormtroopers that was a crap ton of
Stormtroopers uh that we were both a lot
of Storm Troopers there's always a lot
of Storm Troopers I know but not like
that not like in a setup like that I
haven't seen that many in one setup um
we're ooing and a at the the Iron Man
thing that's kind of cool yeah that
thing it's like a it's like a pyramid of
glass and then it's sort of these little
projectors project the the Iron Man suit
like clapping onto the figure it's it
looks that cool one of these
days something like that for you where
it just like switches your shirt just
going to sit here very still in the
chair and it's going to go like it's
just another t-shirt it's like what
would you like Chris to wear now Boop
dress up dress up sure I mean Everyone
likes dress up right you have character
customization in video games why not
have host customization in your live
show yeah think about it Gamespot that's
us anyways uh folks the giveaway Marches
On we've got Witcher Comics we've got uh
no one has actually claimed this yet it
looks like Witcher art which is cool
yeah geralt's cool but in the back is a
little card that gives you access early
beta access to the digital adaptation of
The Witcher Adventure game an upcoming
board game by CD project red also a
digital comic so uh if you want one of
these guys sound off in the gam spot
chat and uh we got some zerls Zer zerol
zerol when you say zerotol sounds like a
prescription drug which it's not I mean
it I don't I don't know they don't look
consumable he's clear cuz he's a dark
Templar and you don't see dark Templars
cuz they usually are invisible thank you
for explaining that to me one of these
words on the front okay go UK de jakan
what does that mean I don't know I don't
even think I've never heard him say that
before myself I don't speak protos I
don't speak oh man I don't even know
you're putting me on the spot I can only
think of high Templar why do you think
you're on the couch to be on the
spot like metaphorically speaking like
that I see where he went with that yeah
yeah I like that all right folks a
reminder that not only are we giving
away uh a bunch of Halo Nightfall poster
still Witcher Comics still uh The
Witcher board game still we've also got
the Nathan Drake yeah courtesy of our
friends at Sideshow Collectibles go
ahead and retweet gamespot's tweet
earlier today for that and the Mega Man
helmet it lights up on its base it's
pretty sick and you can get it by
photoshopping a picture of of a cat as
Mega Man or any of the Mega Man
characters I would like to see like a
like a rush cat that'd be weird actually
was just going to say that but then I
was thinking that sounds kind of weird
yeah we'll be given those those prizes
will be fulfilled next week on uh early
in the week I think one's going to be on
Peter Brown's live stream meab bit at
11: a.m. on Monday uh and the other one
we're going to be giving away on Twitter
because that one is worth a lot of money
apparently don't tell the people that
they should want it because it's because
they love Nate they love Nate Dog yeah
Nate Drake and his half tuck huh remind
what to do the other stuff too oh yeah
so Twitter is how you win these things
but all this stuff on the couch just
call it out in the chat I mean we're in
there we're check we're checking it out
Eric and I are both chatting and Dan is
back here chat with us about what you're
about to see which includes a lot more
cosplay yeah for one which is one of the
best parts of comcon let's be honest I
think so yeah yes naturally uh also
we're going to take a look at Hall h
Eric tell people what is Hall h okay so
no we this docent you you're just
getting tricked left and right maybe I
should you know production cuz you know
I'm normally part of production so like
I know what they're do you know what's
up next it's a thing I got mad about
before really Ubisoft yeah we're going
to actually this time go check out
Ubisoft games they had the crew they had
Assassin's Creed I think there was some
Far Cry 4 in there too so obviously
three big games three of the big ones
being shown at San Diego ComicCon here
we're going to go take a look at them
out in the wild at the Ubisoft booth
Alex Amano creative director on
Assassin's Creed Unity the OB course is
amazing we actually had uh uh a lot of
people come and try it we have good
records but the leap of faith is
actually the funniest one because I mean
when you look at it it's pretty high but
you don't get a real sense of how high
it is until you're up there and we see a
lot of different people uh one one
person stood up there for like an hour
everybody was encouraging and they
couldn't jump another one I mean his
mind wanted to jump but his body just
wouldn't let him he he kept moving
forward and he kept clinging to the the
side of the bar he was like at one point
he was on his knees trying to jump down
was funny but he he ended up jumping so
it's always surprising when you see
people that whose costumes I mean I mean
we're looking at the stuff of Hollywood
like the these costumes are intricate
they're amazing and uh yeah fans uh
really like the universe and we're
really happy to come here and actually
present the game to them and let them
you know have fun in the obstacle course
and even try out the leap of faith so
we're down here I'm creative director on
Far Cry 4 so we're standing here in this
Bliss Ling heat sweating like pigs
showing off our game it's moist it's
moist in Far Cry 4 yeah so so we're
trying to recreate it here in the booth
now we got a we did a we did a panel
we've done a bunch of stuff on this side
it's a really tricky uh uh state where
you want to keep showing people stuff
but at the same time you don't want to
spoil everything you want to have
something you know left to excite people
so there's a bit of that um and also
comic on it's it's it's a good time to
get you know sort of face to face with
fans I really like coming on I push to
come because uh uh people are positive
everyone's here and they're excited you
know uh uh it's not so much uh uh you
know a picky show where everyone's like
trying to find an angle so it's just
nice to come here and talk to fans and
ask answer their questions yeah if you
have a Playstation 3 or a PlayStation 4
you can invite uh uh 10 of your closest
friends um obviously uh we talked a lot
about the world about karats about all
the new toys we have the elephants you
can ride the new vehicles the tuck tuck
the new weapons I'm trying to think of
what what what we're allowed to talk
about what we're not all we've got so
many cool things we still be at to show
um probably I think one of the
interesting things we're talking about
lately is that we've tried to bring the
an Factory like your ability to tell
your own story Into The Narrative as
well so you'll be fighting with the
rebel faction the golden path in Far Cry
4 but you can influence who wins as the
leader of that faction you can change
the direction of the the organization so
we're really trying to get people to
actually tell their own story even
within the narrative this time
around we've got a huge setup inside
where people can play the game inside uh
car carpets so it's a it's the the demo
that we had at E3 uh it's something that
people have been getting a real kick out
of and I've got pictures of uh tiny like
7-year-old Spider-Man playing the game
that I'm sending back to the team it's
going really really well plus we at um
the Xbox Lounge so we're we're a little
bit everywhere and because the game's
playable uh a lot of people are getting
some hands- on time this is the first
public showing of the uh the demo the
One racing game of V3 basically so it's
really conflictual for me cuz I'm having
fun in San Diego but the team back home
uh they're monitoring the uh closed beta
so we launch the closed beta this week
uh we've got you 50 150,000 uh keys that
have been sent out people are playing
and sending us feedback and that's the
feedback you know we've got qualitative
feedback and quantitative feedback and
the the thing that really strikes people
the most is the size of the map you know
that the recreation of the us and this
promise that we had of no loading Drive
from coast to coast if you want that's
real true and people are getting their
hands on and realizing okay it wasn't
just [__] it's actually something
that people can do so we're getting
phenomenally good feedback plus people
are playing together people who don't
know each other that cooperating in
missions they're competing in missions
so it's exactly as we design the game
but it's you know when you launch a
Sandbox game you're never sure and here
it's validating a lot of the choices we
made so it's really positive news so far
the most important important thing is
this Clos beater is just the first step
I think we need to do it again maybe a
second to third beater uh and people can
get some Hands-On get some demo time on
it send us some feedback it's only going
to improve the game for its launch so
I'm I don't have specific dates to
announce but that's something that we
haven't even talked about before so uh
that's an Comic-Con exclusive
there
B
hold
y
he
hi there I'm Anna prer Robinson for
Gamespot here on the front line at s San
Diego Comic-Con 2014 today I am hitting
the show floor in a little cosplay of my
own and I'm on the lookout for the best
Disney
cosplay very good Mulan you look
absolutely stunning and exactly like I
would see you in the movie how did you
come up with a costume like this well I
made it myself and I did the wig which
was fun because I I don't think any
human actually has this much hair um
but I modeled it after the ones in the
Parks so and how did you make this comb
it looks exactly like the one in the
movie oh thanks I made it out of um
paper clay and I painted it and I I
actually had a wooden comb and I like
sculpted over it very very cool what
what made you choose Mulan as the
character to cosplay well I love Mulan
and I love Disney and I physically look
the most like Mulan so I was like oh
it's a Natural
Choice you guys are are dressed together
as Disney characters tell me about your
costumes well we've always loved Disney
and my favorite princess has always been
Ariel so I figured why not be here for a
while and you uh well I'm not into
princesses as you can see oh so I rather
do a villain which love I've seen Ursula
but I've never seen Vanessa very well
done what's your favorite piece of your
costume oh I have to say my contract and
my shell uh since my shell is TR special
it glows actually so I could turn it
on and it glows wow Ariel's voice is in
there
yes hi I'm Anna what's your name I'm
Princess Tiana and Tiana what went into
the making of this beautiful dress
actually I didn't make this but I did
design it I picked out the fabrics and I
drew like my little interpretation and
then I actually had a friend who
designed it for me it's fantastic what
made you want to cosplay Tiana um I've
been cosplaying Princess Tiana since the
movie first came out and um I don't know
she's just when the movie first came out
it was just like such a cool you know
interesting new princess that was out
there so I actually this is actually the
redesign oh very nice dress this is
2.0 I found a friend who looks quite
nice next to me if I do say so myself
what's your name I'm uh I'm Amanda hi
Amanda I'm Anna tell me about what went
into making your costume you said you
made it from head to toe yourself yes um
this is actually my fifth run of the
costume um I hand cut over 2,000 sequins
um laid all the jewels down I took three
wigs and sewed them together so you
really really went for accuracy too you
didn't go for an interpretation cuz this
looks just exactly like it definitely is
the only interpretation I took was I
made different snowflakes for her hair
cuz I I liked the a little bit more
Glitz and and glamour in there I thought
it'd be more fun hi I'm Anna what's your
name I'm Sarah and Sarah tell me about
your cosplay well um obviously Snow
White from Disney um I made it last year
actually in about a week for ComicCon I
got to fix it up a little today so I'm
really happy to be wearing it and you
made it all yourself I did and why did
you choose Snow White um I think her
Design's really cute for one thing I do
love Disney um so I don't know if she's
my favorite character but she's
definitely one of my favorite cost cumes
and she seems to fit you really well
thank you so much did I miss your Disney
cosplay if I did let me know by tweeting
me a picture at
an hi there I'm Anna proa Robinson for
Gamespot here on the front line at San
Diego ComicCon 2014 I'm checking out
cosplay today and you know it's always
fun to cosplay by yourself but it's even
more fun to cosplay in a group we
checked out some of the best best groups
of cosplayers here at Comic-Con
2014 you do all bear a striking
resemblance to the people that you're
cost playing I walked up and it's
immediately clear oh there they are uh
does it help to be playing in a group
like this where people immediately
recognize who you are we get attacked
yes it's yeah a lot of pictures you've
had quite a lot of attention yeah
there's a lot of attention but also we
get moved around by security a lot
because it tents to form a crowd is that
cool for you as somebody who's wanting
to represent a character you really
believe in to show that off here yeah I
really like it it's fun and I think it's
a good way to promote you know feminism
and you know women in comics and in
movies
hey hey hey
hey cosplaying in a group is so much fun
if we cosplayed together what would we
go as tweet @ anaer and let me
know hi there I'm Anna prer Robinson for
Gamespot here on the front line at San
Diego Comic-Con 2014 it's day one and
we're hitting the show floor to find as
much cosplay as possible let's check it
out
tell me a little bit about your cosplay
uh I am Sith Lord kahi from Star Wars
the Old Republic it's my own personal
character uh my character is uh Lauren
from Angel the series which is The Buffy
the vampires spin-off and uh he was my
favorite character in the whole show
because he was this very flamboyant
demon who owns a karaoke
bar
I've run into some Avengers what's your
name Captain America what's yours
Captain America's favorite Uso girl
what's yours Thor god of thunder and you
Hawkeye it looks very convincing what
about you um about 30 hours of glue
spray paint and foam the foam is this is
that what this is made out of all fo
bottom of spray spray paint cans turned
inside out very resourceful and and how
long did it take to create the hair D
well that's why I witness Thor because I
wasn't about to shave or cut my hair and
it just fit so I said Thor I
am just uh 237 different stuffed animals
wrapped in a two-piece suit that's
amazing yes it's uh pretty hot
but it's worth it it's worth
it
well this is only day one so there's
sure to be lots more cosplay in store
for us let me know if you're going to be
wearing something awesome or you've seen
awesome costumes on the show floor by
tweeting @ Anna
procer big thanks to Anna procer
Robinson for all those check-ins from
all over the place at San Diego Comic
Con one of the uh folks bringing us and
you guys a lot of the flavor of
Comic-Con outside of our awesome live
stage show here Justin hayal is joining
us now you've been out and about as well
my friend I have and the reason I'm here
is cuz I had some breaking news bre bre
news I was incredibly unimpressed with
your reaction to this news because I was
that's not the breaking news okay the
breaking news is not talking crap about
me man anyway so I just came from the
Monster Hunter 4 panel and at the very
it was going long like it was basically
a PowerPoint presentation about Monster
Hunter 4 and at the very end of he's
like all right we're running out of time
I'm just going to show you this one
trailer and we'll get out of here and
you hear the Zelda music come on and you
see link come out in the Monster Hunter
4 Universe just start wailing on
Monsters with the master sword and his
shield it's like so link is going to be
a playable character in Monster Hunter 4
ultimate on 3DS well when you describe
it like that it sounds really cool it
was totally awesome before you just came
in you're like hey guys link link is
going to be in Monster not how I said it
I I was giddy with interpretation that's
pretty accurate yeah going with what
Chris said he was like oh yeah that
that's just how I am in general though
cool but it's really cool he also so the
trailer is probably going to be up on
the Capcom Community blog and also on
gamespot.com pretty soon um so they
showed him fighting with the master
sword but also using all of the
traditional Monster Hunter weapons so
he's fully integrated into the game it
looks like it's not maybe it's a costume
so it's it's more than just you know
like here's oneoff character that you
can do a couple missions and it looks
like you'll be able to like take his
full costume all of his weapons and play
as him basically in the game right on uh
do we have like Boomerang bow and arrow
hook shot Etc yeah no we we saw him like
up climbing some ladders throw it a
boomerang he and he did not play the flu
there is a a wind instrument in the game
so he didn't have the Ocarina but he had
all of his Tred bow and arrow as well
which is Al a part of regular Monster
Hunter but they made all of the weapons
look like they fit in that Zelda
universe as well so really really cool
and what better place to show that off
than ComiCon of course you know when you
want breaking video game news you come
to ComicCon I know I was just I was
waiting for that exclusive to come out I
Al so literally I was sitting there in
the panel and I'm chatting with one of
my other news guys because he's going to
help me write up stuff and I'm like yeah
there's there's not going to be anything
here it's just a PowerPoint presentation
about Monster Hunter 4 weapons and
monsters and then at the very end I was
like oh [__] never mind there's a
there's links start writing this now
just put it up on the site like I I have
no assets just put a picture of Link
just put it up there we got to go that's
how the news breaks Justin hayal thank
you for coming on sharing that news no
thanks for having me I'm very excited
I'm going to go play play it and you
also did you also get yourself from swag
I so I went over to the kamicon the
blizzard panel and I bought one of these
because there was no line oh my God
what's wrong with you people this there
was no line to get one of these what
appeals to you about zerol these clear
yeah that's can't see just clear come on
he's cloaked get it right he's cloaked
but he he's clear here he's not very
cloaked I can see him I I mean I can see
him Tay too literal he's he's right
there God you guys are the worst he's
inside the Box pretty clearly worst all
right well we are giving away all this
stuff still got some Zer tools up for
grabs some Witcher Comics uh but most of
it has been claimed by our Gamespot
Chatters thank you guys so much for
being in the chat for being in the chat
on twitch.tv/ Gamespot as well it's been
fun to chat with you you guys throughout
our live show two reminders about the
big stuff we're giving away we've got
the Mega Man helmet light up on its
pedestal dealio this is like a real rare
Comic-Con type deal to win that go ahead
and get a picture of a cat make it look
like Mega Man do some photoshop magic
and then tweet it to Gamespot and PC
Brown on Twitter that's Peter Brown's
Twitter handle he'll be adjudicating on
all the images and inside this big one
from our friends at Sideshow
Collectibles Nathan Drake from Uncharted
3 he's doing this mantle job he's got
the AK in his hand he looks really cool
it's a big statue about that big about
that big anyways it's in there we're
going to send it to you if you retweet
gamespot's giveaway tweet that was
posted earlier this morning and we're
going to be giving that away early next
week uh tons of fun stuff coming out of
San Diego ComicCon Eric Tay thank you
for joining me on the shows man than you
for having me didn't want you to be
alone anymore you know I appreciate it
I really do locked in this room a long
time with no one else I it's very cold I
think I'm the only person at ComicCon
who's like cold or well me and Dan and
Julio and Jen and Ryan and all the guys
who are here running the show uh so yeah
that's it for games spots live coverage
of San Diego ComicCon 2014 thank you so
much for watching congratulations all
the giver winners of our giveaways the
givers of our winways yeah givers uh if
you didn't of course if you're watching
the show you saw a lot of our videos
from comic com but there are more on the
site there's more articles previews and
news of course be sure to check all that
stuff out over the weekend and we'll see
you back here on Gamespot for more live
show goodness on Monday thanks again
have a great
weekend Chris Waters watch on the table
should I I you can keep it on or on the
floor just seems a little weird to put
on the table it's like I will I will
give it away if it's on the table I will
call like a a tweet if it's on the table
it's Gamespot
property okay goad Brian Hong watch yep
that
is did we get a shot of that I think we
should do the whole demo that way I
don't want to distract so Brian I don't
want to dist I watch distract something
seems different about you
yes we got
chis
house guys are interested in all right
that's
proba you like when I do fetch on oh my
God I want to enjoy it on the go do you
have like a mobile version yeah we sell
a bottle it's a portable bottle okay
yeah all right bottled ice coffee uhhuh
okay I got you all right and is that
that but is that compatible with the DLC
or is there there's sort of a separate
thing going on right so you're going to
have to buy uh there's different DLC
it's more of an insert okay if you go
with the bottle version uhhuh U but you
get the same experience you get the same
type of coffee the same sort of uh you
know price structure and let's be honest
who doesn't love ice
coffee welcome to
Karma please tell me if you recorded
that don't go viral like
that be GI been around the block yes
yeah i' I've seen things I've done
things I've done things
anyways well we've got a lot of
enthusiasm in the chat here for iced
coffee a lot of questions coming in too
do you mind ify yeah okay uh well um I
guess they' they've had experience with
other Beverages and like adding uh
flavors to them sort of char sort of
customization if you will right we're
not ready to talk about any flavors just
yet okay uh it's something we're working
on but uh you know as long as the fans
are telling us what they want I'm sure
we're going to try our best to give it
to them that's you know that's all right
okay so did you see that video do you
know what American I saw American Ninja
Warrior but I don't I don't know the
person she was the first woman to do do
the course and it was incredible cuz
she's also like not that tall much
taller than 5T so like stuff that other
people can just reach like leap between
did she make it all the like up the up
that big tall shaft and everything oh
did that she made that look like it was
[__] cake wow
like that's crazy it was incredible
that's coming out this fall
steam Xbox One and PS4 be sure to keep
an eye out for release date news on
gamespot.com as Phoenix rages release
date
approaches but oh and maybe we'll give
some of these away on Twitter
yeah whenever you're ready Mr Chris
Waters all
right this is how it professional
polishes his expensive device is that
how you get mentally prepared rubbing
your tablet on your thigh there it is
all right yeah visualizing it stroke the
go there you go
Focus all right okay so if there I mean
is there a place that you know you guys
have a a forum or like a Twitter handle
that people can reach out to to you so
ice cough. okay you can go there and
there is a form you can fill out and uh
there are some flavors to choose from
but we have other ideas that if people
you know want there's a field they can
write in things they want to get a
little creative there yeah and like
luckily our our engine for this is
pretty straightforward it's just water
and beans okay so if people want to add
something you know I'm pretty sure we
can make that happen it's not well yeah
I mean the I think in terms of the the
beverage genre the mod Community is just
so vibrant
I yes I have to make up for my lack of
skill in this game
excellent making up for lack of skill
with Showmanship I approve good checking
Sebastian rard creative producer thank
you very much yeah all right
success all and the face we have to
change the face I'm sorry yeah that's
not
Sebastian it's all
wrong man I look really different on
camera
turn